It turns out that that something else is the square root of 2. When we multiply
the square root of 2 by the square root of 2, we get the number 2. We know this
is true since we can rewrite this as the square root of 2 squared. We use our
knowledge of fractional exponents to rewrite this radical as 2 to the 1 half.
We're raising a power to a power so we multiply these exponents together to get
2 times 1 half, or 2 divided by 2. This leaves us with 2 to the 1, which is
simply 2. Now, we're not so much interested in multiplication of radicals right
now, we'll run that later. But what we are interested in is the square root 2.
This is an irrational number. And the irrational number is a number that
doesn't terminate. It means that whatever is after the decimal never ends. The
square root of 2 is about 1.4, but that's just an approximation. This decimal
actually has an infinite number of places following the decimal point, it goes
on forever. So, when we think about irrational numbers, we're just thinking
about numbers that can't be written as a fraction. It's not important to plug a
number like the square root of 2 into your calculator since we really only get
an approximation of that answer. Throughout the rest of this unit, we won't be
working with these crazy decimals. Instead, we'll just write the radical symbol
and the number.